The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I've prepared
some slides, of course,
but I don't know, please
interrupt at any time
and ask questions, OK?
I've sort of got a big panorama
of things to talk about.
It's basically impossible
to cover everything, OK?
I mean, basically I
advertise this talk
as an outlook for the
future, and of course, that's
too broad.
So I've picked a
few things which
are of special interest
to me, and what
they are are the possible
pathways to nuclear war.
Now, as you know, what
I talk about often
is in comparing the danger
to the planet, and of course,
its population, of climate
change and nuclear war.
So climate change is just--
I think the probability is
pretty close to 100%.
I don't know how to quantify
it, but it's fairly certain
that we are into an
era of global warming
and its consequences.
And this is a slow,
steady thing in terms
of probability of occurrence
with all its ramifications.
Nuclear war is much
easier to avoid,
but if it happens-- and
of course, every day
the probability is very low.
That's what I call the
probability structure.
So the probability of a nuclear
war any specific day is low.
The cumulative probability
is higher, of course.
And if that event occurs,
it's catastrophic.
So what happens is the
destruction just starts in.
The destruction, of course,
is local in the place
where the weapon blows up.
The destruction, it depends
how many bombs go off
and how much soot
goes into the air,
but we could have
global consequences
if there are enough of them.
A so-called nuclear winter.
So having said that, I
just want to talk about--
and this is the fear, of course.
And that's what keeps some of
us worrying about this problem
and working on it.
So basically I want to talk
about the possible pathways
to nuclear war.
I'll talk a little bit
about proliferation
and the
Non-Proliferation Treaty.
I'll say just a few words
about the possibility
of nuclear weapons abolition.
I'll talk a wee bit about
Obama's record and the outlook.
That's a pretty
ambitious agenda.
There are endless debates about
the utility of nuclear weapons.
Some people are at
least pro having them.
Not using them, but having
them, because, of course,
they were pro in the one
case that they were used,
and of course, we used them
on Hiroshima and Nagasaki.
One group of people
says that actually saved
lives because the war ended
more quicker that way.
I think that's highly
debatable, but it's
a point of view which is held.
So it actually saved casualties
and it prevented World War III.
These are some of the arguments.
I'm not trying to
give all of them,
but these are arguments that
you can find in the literature.
And you can find books, and
this just goes back and forth.
And of course, the
counter argument
was that the use of
atomic weapons in Japan
was not necessary.
What was really
necessary was to agree
that the Emperor could
stay on, and that
turned out to be the
key that people argue.
And certainly almost
everyone agrees
that the use of the
second bomb in Nagasaki
was something that should
not have been done.
I think there's much
more agreement to that.
There are books that
this use was actually
the first step of the Cold War.
Of course, many
Japanese civilians
were killed, several
hundred thousand,
and two cities were destroyed.
On the other hand, we destroyed
almost all the major cities
in Japan by
conventional weapons.
And of course, Japan did not
have an unblemished record
in Korea and China and so forth.
I'm not going to go into
that, but the moral dimensions
of World War II are
pretty horrible.
I'll stop there.
The inhibition about
killing civilians
pretty much disappeared
in World War I
and was just totally ignored
in World War II, I would say.
And in the post-war
era, the argument
is that you didn't
need nuclear weapons
to prevent a war between the
United States and the Soviet
Union.
I pretty much think
that's the case myself.
So here are the questions.
There have been no nuclear
wars since the first two
weapons were used.
Of course, there have
been many explosions,
but they were tests.
So was that deterrence?
There's a theory
about nuclear taboo
because they're
morally so awful.
I'm a bit skeptical,
but it's a theory
that's out there by an
important Yale sociologist.
Is it luck, other
reasons, and so forth.
So many of us-- well, I'll
give you some of my conclusions
at the end, but the
crucial question
is does the possession
of nuclear weapons
make a country more secure?
You heard this in
the case of Ukraine
when the Russians took the
Crimean, when they basically
have their stealth invasion
of the Ukraine, which
is going on as we speak.
Would a Ukrainian nuclear
weapon deter them?
And when the Soviet Union
broke up in the end of 1991,
there was a lot of discussion
about what would happen
to all the nuclear weapons.
They were mostly in Russia,
Ukraine, and Kazakhstan.
And we managed to
persuade the Ukrainians--
they were the toughest--
and the Kazakhs
to give all those
weapons to Russia.
But in fact, one of the
things-- and there's
a lot of history here-- but
one of the best articles
that I've read, and I
think it's obviously true,
states that in fact the Ukraine
and Kazakhstan never really
owned those weapons.
They were really owned
by the Soviet Union.
The Ukrainian army was
not prepared to take them
in any way.
They really didn't have an army.
They hardly have an army now,
20 years later or something.
So there's no realistic
way that the Ukrainians
had a nuclear weapon
that could be used.
They had possession
of nuclear weapons,
but not the actual
ability to use them.
So it's a very funny thing.
It's a very special case,
and it's a very funny thing.
But that argument is heard.
I would say more important,
or at least as important,
is is the present
situation stable?
This is a key question.
Many people doubt it
that our good fortune
in not having any nuclear
exchanges since 1945
is purely deterrence.
if there isn't an element of
luck or other issues involved.
And each specific
case is different.
So it's hard to generalize.
I mean, one of the issues,
one of the differences
between physics
and arms control,
is how the lack
in arms control is
the lack, really, of science.
How much more difficult the
situation is to evaluate.
And of course, now
with relationships
between the United
States and Russian,
in fact, the whole west and
Russia at a low point, probably
a few decade old low point,
the future of arms control
seems bleak at this
moment, I have to say.
It's hard to maintain optimism.
And finally there's
this perennial question
about abolishing
nuclear weapons, which
is certainly more and more
remote as time goes on.
But I think as
academics we should
think about it, because these
are very important issues.
So we should think long-range
is what I'm saying.
It's not going to happen
quickly, obviously.
If at all.
But is it desirable?
There are two
separate questions.
Is it desirable and
is it going to happen.
So immediately after the
development of the atomic bomb,
there were intense discussions
inside of the Manhattan Project
before the public knew about it.
And there was this
famous Franck Report,
and the conclusions of the
Franck Report are here.
Use the bomb for a
demonstration, not on cities.
Share the secret.
The secret-- not necessary
the details of how to make it.
I don't think anyone
ever proposed that.
What's meant here is share
the secret of its existence
before its use.
That's what they're
talking about.
Because the use without notice,
particularly without notice
to the Soviet
Union, would ensure
the start of a war, a Cold
War, and a nuclear arms race.
And that's exactly what
the scientists predicted.
These were very
sophisticated people.
Franck was a Nobel
Laureate from Germany
who escaped from Hitler.
And there were many other
things that happened.
The scientists banded together.
They formed the Bulletin
of the Atomic Scientists,
the Federation of Atomic
Scientists, which still goes on
although it's not
as strong as it was.
And they developed this
Acheson-Lilienthal plan,
in which Oppenheimer
played a major role.
And it ended up as the
Baruch plan, which was not
really what was proposed, and
it was turned down immediately
by the Soviet Union
for various reasons.
I can go into them, but I won't.
So the era of possible
arms control in 1945,
1946, collapsed in the beginning
of the Cold War period.
And what the scientists
feared the most happened.
And the other thing
is-- and you hear this
from the people who
first developed the bomb
and then worked as actively
as they could against it,
and many of them were at MIT.
Some of the names
you know very well.
Victor Weisskopf.
There was Hans
Bethe from Cornell.
And there was just a
whole group of people,
very prominent scientists.
And Hans Bethe-- both Viki
Weisskopf and Hans Bethe
told me personally, but they
said it many times in public,
that when we realized
in about 1946
that there was no agreement
was going to happen,
we asked ourselves, what is the
worst thing that could happen?
And they said, we would
build a hundred weapons.
100.
And the Russians would
build 100 weapons.
And then we would face each
other down with 100 weapons.
That was the worst these
sophisticated, bright men could
imagine in 1946.
So what did people expect?
First, the atomic
scientists, they
thought that the nuclear
weapon was so horrible
it would change the
behavior of mankind.
And politicians like
Churchill and Roosevelt
believed that this
powerful weapon
would allow England
and the United States,
with their monopoly,
to be able to say
the way the world evolved.
So both sides were wrong.
Typical.
So the influence that it had
has been reasonably small.
We never got the Russians
to agree to almost anything
we wanted them to do.
For example, they took
over Eastern Europe.
We hated that.
They did it.
Et cetera.
You know, it just
goes on and on.
The Communists took China.
We hated that.
The list of things-- I just
mentioned a few major ones.
So that's what I mean by
its coercive influence.
Its possession became a status
symbol almost right away.
But there is some
deterrence in it.
Deterrence isn't
completely useless.
Deterrence and abhorrence,
a combination of the two
of them I think,
works to some extent.
So there's been a non-use.
Now, I want you to
look at this graph.
This is the buildup of
nuclear weapons between us
and the Soviet Union.
And you notice this scale?
5,000, 10,000.
100 is down here.
The Soviet Union blew
up their first bomb
four years after we
did, as predicted.
Not only was it predicted
that they would get the bomb,
but that it would take
them three to five years.
That was the number that was
given by the atomic scientists.
And it was hotly disputed
in Washington, but so what.
And again, we built up
to astronomical numbers.
Tens of thousands of weapons.
And finally we
have a slow decline
through nuclear arms
control agreements
and through terrifying events,
like the Cuban Missile Crisis.
And the spirit of
that build up is,
I think, exemplified
in this great cartoon,
which you can read for yourself,
from the middle of the Cold
War.
And I think this says the story.
AUDIENCE: Is that
the only reason?
PROFESSOR: Fear.
AUDIENCE: Fear is
the only reason?
PROFESSOR: Fear.
Well, I mean, they developed
all kinds of fancy strategies,
but at the heart of it was fear.
Just plain fear of a
devastating first strike.
And then you had to build up
counterforce capabilities,
be able to absorb
the first strike,
and able to destroy the
enemy after the first strike.
But the astronomical
number was mad.
And it was called MAD,
Mutual Assured Destruction.
It was literally called MAD.
Those of us looking
from the outside--
but we weren't really
on the outside,
because we would have been the
victims-- thought it was mad.
But you know, logic
is in a certain sense,
irrelevant in this situation.
I mean, there's such a
grip of fear on both sides.
And it's really true.
I sat through the
Cuban Missile Crisis
personally with a
dedicated Russian
Communist who had actually
come to work in my laboratory.
It was a very
interesting experience.
He thought it was all the
fault of the United States.
Most of the people
thought it was
the fault of the Soviet Union.
Most of the people here.
But I thought they were
both at fault. You know,
I thought-- not that they
were equally nice people,
but that they were just
operating from too much fear.
So they overdid it.
You know, this business
of a hundred weapons.
I often ask students in class
how many weapons are enough,
and nobody knows how to
answer that question.
But then I say,
well, how many cities
are you willing to give up?
You now, in the case of
the Russians, is it Moscow?
Leningrad?
That's two cities.
And there's a famous exchange
between Jerome Wiesner, who
was ex-president of
MIT, and also a science
adviser the Kennedy, with
Gorbachev where he asked them
exactly this question.
And Gorbachev was just amazed.
So well, there you go.
So I think it's fear
and distrust, of course.
Fear and distrust,
they go together.
And that's very important.
I just want to point out that
one of our nuclear submarines--
this is the maximum
loading, by the way.
They're loaded a little less
now, but it doesn't matter.
I don't change this slide.
But basically they have 100
and 300 kiloton warheads.
So in order of magnitude,
larger than the Hiroshima weapon
on Nagasaki.
And each submarine has a
maximum loading, it should say,
of 96 warheads.
They're independently targeted.
You can destroy 96 targets.
After firing, it takes 10 or
15 minutes to reach Russia.
So you could-- it's
kind of staggering.
So the total explosive
power is three times that
of World War II.
One submarine.
It's incredible.
This is the present global
inventory, more or less.
You can see-- this is
the number that counts.
These are the
strategic warheads,
and you can see there
the order of 1,500, which
is this new START Treaty limit.
We're just about at
that limit anyway.
And that all the other countries
have typically a few hundred
at the most.
This is all guesswork
as to the numbers.
It's not known.
I think 10 for North
Korea is probably
a factor of two to
three high, but it
gives an order of magnitude.
This is guesswork, frankly,
because these are all secret.
So people do the best they can.
This is a table from Hans
Kristensen and the Federation
of American Scientists who keeps
track of these things as well
as he can.
AUDIENCE: How can they
make these guesses?
PROFESSOR: Oh, they
look at the literature
and they look at
budgets and they
look at satellite pictures.
They do their best.
I think they have the
right order of magnitude,
but nobody claims they
know the exact number.
I mean, if you talk to Hans
Kristensen, who's very good,
and who knows what he's doing,
he's very smart and competent.
He'll tell you this
is educated guesswork.
But it's more or
less-- it's enough.
You know, I mean, 90
or a hundred weapons.
It's all-- a hundred
weapons is overkill.
AUDIENCE: But is
it usually the case
where the countries would
want to make that number
look higher or lower than that?
PROFESSOR: They want it
to be higher so that--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right?
Except for Israel, which doesn't
want to admit it has any,
but they want it known anyway.
So it's a complex game.
But for most of the
other countries,
they say it's for deterrence.
So it's better to let your
adversary know what you've got.
China is also very coy
about their numbers,
because they have
relatively few numbers,
and they want to keep this--
positions secret and all
of that.
So they don't want to have-- and
they don't keep their missiles
on alert either.
China's a very
interesting country
with respect to nuclear weapons.
And perhaps exceptional.
So the pathways to nuclear
escalation and war,
as I've stressed, is fear.
Fear, to me, is
the biggest factor.
I'm sure people
will argue with me.
Every point I'm
making at some level
as controversial, by the way.
I'm not trying to
hide it, but it's
just I can't give
you every nuance.
You know, it's one hour.
People write books
about each subject.
So, you know, have
to oversimplify it.
But anyway, I consider the
two possible pathways to War.
One is an accidental launch
between the United States
and Russia.
And the other is escalation
from conventional war
in India and Pakistan.
Now, somewhat less likely is
North Korea's use of a weapon,
but I suspect they
won't, because I
think that they are constrained
by other military reasons
on the Korean peninsula.
So North Korea wants to
rattle the sword, so to speak,
but they, I think, really
want it for both deterrence
and, as far as I can tell,
for the survivability
of the regime.
Which is a whole
other-- but that
comes into all these things.
That's why each case is special.
North Korea's a
very special case.
It's a very odd
government, and so forth.
Now, we had-- Vipin Narang
talked about escalation
from conventional war, and he
talked about the deployment.
One of the things
he talks about,
which I think is very
sound, is that this whole
issue when you talk
about deterrence,
it isn't just numbers.
There's a whole other
dimension, at least.
And one is the
deployment posture.
And Pakistan has a very
aggressive deployment posture,
because they feel inferior in
conventional weapons to India.
And they feel threatened
by India in many ways.
And they've already been
partitioned by India
when the country broke up into
the eastern and western part,
Bangladesh and India.
So there's a historic enmity
between the two, which
needs to be-- and I want
to-- it needs to be fixed.
And I have to say,
personally, that I
was very disappointed
with Obama's visit
to India in many respects.
You know, I look at
the nuclear issue,
and that's one of my lenses.
It isn't my sole lens, but
it's an important focus for me.
And what I see is Obama talks
about the climate, which
is excellent, then he gets
on this very poor policy
of selling nuclear energy,
nuclear reactors, to India
and not exempting India
from the restrictions that
used to be in place
before the Bush
administration of exempting
India from the restrictions
we've placed on
them because they
violated the Non-Proliferation
Treaty and tested weapons.
Now of course,
Pakistan did so, also.
But the point is that
we just aggravate
the Indian-Pakistan tension.
As far as I can tell, and
I just read The New York
Times, you know, and listen to
the BBC, as far as I can tell,
the subject of
treating Pakistan,
of defusing the tension with
Pakistan, did not arise.
As far as I can.
At least these there was
no public mention of it.
And I was very disappointed.
And Obama's also trying to
draw-- India is more concerned
with China than with Pakistan.
This is a sort of
three-way dance,
if you want to put it that way.
And so it's more complicated
than a bipolar interaction.
It's a three-way game where
China frightens India, India
frightens Pakistan.
China ends up helping
Pakistan with nuclear issues
and nuclear weapons issues.
They originally gave Pakistan
the design for the bomb.
So this is something
that if India
wants to solve this
issue of Pakistan's
aggressive deployment,
they either
have to do it by force,
which won't work,
because India has been deterred.
Or they have to do
it through diplomacy,
and it always ends
up with this message.
You can use force,
which won't work,
or you can use diplomacy,
which has a chance.
Which is difficult,
but has a chance.
Those are the two ways
to solve the problem.
So how could a war start by
accident between US and Russia?
Well, basically the
most likely path
is a malfunctioning of
the Early Warning system.
So here's a chilling quote
from Vice President Cheney,
when he was Vice President.
I'll just let you
read it for a minute.
The famous football
he's talking about.
Or black box.
And this is carried around
wherever the President
of the United States goes.
There's somebody a few doors
down, 24/7, who can say,
Mr. President, we're under fire.
Here's the button.
Now, it actually isn't
a physical button,
but that doesn't matter.
That's irrelevant.
It's the equivalent
of a physical button.
It's a virtual button.
So this is chilling.
And you ask, what
about the Constitution?
What about consulting?
What about anything?
No, because of the 10-minute,
the 30-minute launch time
and the 10-minute warning time.
So we have roughly
a thousand missiles,
and so does Russia,
on hair trigger alert.
They're ready to be
fired at minutes' notice.
The number's probably
closer to 900, but so what.
I mentioned the delivery
times and decision times.
So the probability of an
error is not negligible.
It is true, this is a complex
physical, emotional system.
It's a human system with fear.
I keep emphasizing
this, because there
is fear, a very basic fear.
And each side-- what hawks don't
realize is that on each side
is vulnerable to
the other's system.
You cannot stop the attack.
All you can do is retaliate.
In other words, it's
deter or revenge.
Those are the two
modes of operation.
This is chilling, but
that is the world we've
been living in for 50 years.
Literally.
People don't think about
it, but it's pretty awful.
Now, the fact is that the
Russian system is less robust.
So we are actually
more vulnerable
than they are, except that
we'll fire if they do.
And of course,
why does it go on?
Each side does it because
the other side does it.
It's sort of nutty.
This is not logic.
This is not normal logic.
This is a tight circle.
And so the latest that has
surfaced in the last few years
is cyber attack.
So you ask how this can happen.
Well, a cyber attack.
Just imagine, somebody
hacks into the system,
somebody who really wants
the United States and Russia
to destroy each other,
hacks into the Early
Warning system of either side.
Just imagine that.
That's a nightmare.
So the irony, as I mentioned,
is that the safety of each side
depends on the other
side not launching.
And then of course, there's
the political question,
why do we persist?
Obama promised to do
something about it
when he came to office,
but he has given it up.
He's clearly given it
up without explanation.
But it was one of his promises.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You would think
even with the tensions that
exist that we would both be
better off if this system were
up.
PROFESSOR: Of course.
The more tension there is,
the more scary this is.
It's less scary when there's
no tension, obviously.
It's fear, again.
And all the things
that go with fear.
AUDIENCE: And distrust.
PROFESSOR: Fear-- yeah.
I'm going taking them
almost as synonymous.
Distrust because the other
side has the capability
to destroy you.
And a second strike
capability, in the language
of Cold War-- you
know, you ask why
it happens with all
this strategic doctrine,
but a second strike capability
and launch on warning
are physically identical
with a first strike posture.
So you cannot tell.
I mean, the other side
tells you, we love you.
But it's like having a
guest over for dinner
when the guest comes
with a loaded Uzi.
Not just a pistol, but a
high-powered weapon, and
says, oh, yes.
We're pals.
I'm here for dinner.
You know, what kind
of pals are these?
Right?
I mean, it's a little nutty.
But maybe who am I to judge?
So I want to talk a little bit
about the Non-Proliferation
Treaty, because I think it's--
one of the things that's very
important in this world is that
nuclear weapons don't spread
to other countries.
And the cornerstone of that is
the Non-Proliferation Treaty.
And, honestly, I think in
the nuclear weapons states,
particularly in the
United States and Russia,
the NPT is not taken as
seriously as it should be.
And I think it's very important.
The NPT is taken seriously
for half of what it does.
Namely, it says that
people should not
acquire nuclear weapons.
But it is not taken seriously,
because it obligates
the five nuclear powers,
established nuclear powers,
to give up their
nuclear weapons.
And this is really the heart of
abolition of nuclear weapons,
because it's built-in.
It's Article VI of the
Non-Proliferation Treaty.
It obligates us to do it.
And so there's a
tremendous tension.
I'll come back to
this in a minute.
But the tension is
between the countries who
gave up aspirations for
nuclear weapons saying
to the nuclear weapons powers,
OK, you are obligated to do it.
But the nuclear
weapons countries say,
we're doing it very
gradually and responsibly.
And now-- I'll talk more about
this-- the non-nuclear weapons
states want,
really, a timetable.
So there's a lot of
tension over this.
And I'll come to
this in a minute.
So the cornerstones,
as I mentioned,
Article VI nonproliferation,
disarmament.
And I write disarmament
and in black,
although they're all
extremely important.
I do this for a US audience.
But the last point is that
there's a five-year review.
Every five years
there's a review.
The next one will be
this May, and there
are going to be fireworks.
So I'll talk about that.
So how effective is the NPT?
So there are four states outside
the treaty, Israel, India,
Pakistan, North Korea.
There was this AQ Khan
Network from Pakistan,
which was shut down.
It's never been
absolutely clear how much
the Pakistani state
was involved or if this
was a private venture.
Scott Kemp talked
interestingly about how
the actual material that was
sold by the AQ Khan Network
actually setback
countries like Iran
and their development
of centrifuges.
Because what was sold
was a technology which
was obsolete and inefficient.
So it's very ironic.
So a few countries have given
up their bombs-- oh, excuse me.
And many countries have given
up nuclear weapons programs.
I've listed some of them.
There are many
nuclear-capable countries
that don't have weapons.
Japan is one of them, of course.
Not surprisingly.
Canada.
Our friends in Canada.
But even South Korea, that feels
very threatened by North Korea,
has no bomb.
But they are quite capable.
And the main point
I want to make
is that fewer countries have
nuclear weapons that were
predicted in the early '60s.
Like, famously, Kennedy, JFK,
said aloud that in a few years,
15 to 25 countries would
have nuclear weapons.
And he was reflecting
what the US intelligence
agencies told him.
He wasn't making this up.
It wasn't just a speech.
He was reflecting
what he was told.
And right now,
the political norm
is to renounce nuclear weapons
and press the ones that
have it to disarm.
And that is a big plus and
one that needs encouragement.
There are problems with
the NPT, of course.
Life isn't perfect.
North Korea, in my view, is
the most serious problem.
Well, Pakistan-- I haven't
even written it down here,
but Pakistan and India
are bigger problems
because of the possible
pathways to war.
I already said that.
I didn't want to repeat it.
That's why it's
not on the slide.
But the whole issue with Iran.
There's no question that Iran's
enrichment capabilities exceed
what they can do for power.
In other words, they are very
well-suited for making weapons
and not for power, because they
don't produce enough enriched
uranium for power needs.
But they do produce
enough for weapons.
And that's been clear since
the beginning of the program,
despite what is said.
And so there's been a
tremendous tension there.
I just want to talk a little bit
about the ongoing negotiations.
They're making a
lot of news now.
It's very important, because
we have an interim agreement,
and this is the
time, six months--
it's really four months
on the political level
and six months on
the technical level,
to reach a final agreement.
That's what was set up.
I mean, the first one was
supposed to be six months.
It was extended.
Well, excuse me.
The first phase agreement
was for six months,
and then it's been
extended-- it's not on here--
but it's been extended
for six more months.
So the deadline for
the political agreement
is in March, and then
in June, I think,
is the deadline, the
official deadline.
People are skeptical,
but I don't know.
There are some technical issues.
The Iraq reactor can
produce plutonium.
But there are a simple
solutions to that.
There are simple
technical fixes,
and Iran has agreed to
them, as I understand it.
So that the amount of plutonium
production from the Iraq
reactor will be small.
In the interim
agreement there's not
supposed to be any
additional sanctions.
That's very important in
terms of the US Congress,
because bills have circulated
demanding new sanctions.
But they're probably in
abeyance, fortunately.
There are really four
parties involved,
the two official
parties and then the
hardliners on both sides.
So this is a
complex negotiation.
Within each side it's complex.
I can't go into all of it.
And I think people know
what's going on better
here on the American side.
But the real issue, as far as
I can see it, in terms of Iran,
what Iran wants is
to have, I think,
the Ayatollah said something
like 15,000 centrifuges.
The West, the most hardline
people in the West say zero.
Netanyahu, for example.
Zero is the only acceptable
number of centrifuges.
And that's why he's
campaigning so hard against it,
because he knows
that there will be
no deal with zero centrifuges.
So he already knows in
advance that what he wants
is not possible.
AUDIENCE: How many do
they need to really power
a nuclear power
plant in the future?
PROFESSOR: Well, they need
probably 20,000 advanced ones.
Advanced ones, not what they
have, the so-called P1s.
Ones that work really well.
I don't know off
the top of my head,
but to supply-- what is it?
Bushehr?
Is that the right
pronunciation?--
the Bushehr reactor.
Which they don't
need, by the way,
because Russia's going
to supply the fuel.
But they don't quite
trust Russia, of course,
for reasonable reasons, I think.
But anyway, this whole
business is so murky,
in my personal opinion.
It's hard to tell facts
from motive, in my opinion.
I don't think I can
do it, honestly.
I'll talk with you
privately if you want,
but I don't think I can
really evaluate it in a way
that I would consider
satisfactory.
I can speculate.
That's what I can do.
But the point is-- you
know, there's an old saying
that the ideal solution gets in
the way of the good solution.
The good solution,
in my opinion,
is pretty much to continue the
interim agreement that we have.
Why is that good?
Because what people are not
talking about in the United
States is the best thing
about the whole negotiation.
Namely, that Iran keeps
saying they don't want
to develop nuclear weapons.
And there's a fatwa.
That's excellent.
Second, Iran says that they
want to be part of the NPT.
They are enduring-- and
I'm going to use that word,
enduring-- the most
rigorous inspection
regime that the IAEA, that's
the international agency that
inspects, the
International Atomic Energy
Agency-- they are enduring
the most rigorous inspections
that any country ever endured.
Those are two excellent things.
There are people on the
ground all the time.
People say, well,
they can break out.
Yes, they can break
out if they want to.
They will only
agree to all of this
if it's in their self-interest.
Nobody can expect anything
more of them or us.
So I think what we've got is the
best possible solution that's
feasible.
And if they kick inspectors out
and decide to go for a bomb,
because it's close to
impossible for them
to do a bomb without kicking
the inspectors out, and--
AUDIENCE: Even if they
have hidden sites?
PROFESSOR: Well, they
would have to then develop
so many thousand
more centrifuges
and have that material
and no news could leak out
and all of that stuff.
There are opposition groups.
We found out about some of the
sites-- I forget which one.
The one that's underground.
I forgot the name of it--
through dissenters in Iran.
It always can happen.
The Soviet Union found out
about the Manhattan Project
in a most remarkable way.
I want to talk about
that for a minute,
because that's really important.
In 1940, a Soviet
nuclear physicist,
a very good one named
Flyorov, realized
that all the publications
about fission
in the United States, England,
and France had stopped.
And he went to Stalin
and said, the West
is developing an
atomic bomb, based
on what was not appearing
in the literature.
This is remarkable.
And it's a fact.
Of course, the Soviet
Union had spies,
and they found out about
the Manhattan Project
through the spies.
But Flyorov, just reading
the physical review--
this is a remarkable story
which should not be ignored.
So I think we'd find out.
Maybe slowly, but, you know.
And if they really want
the weapon as a deterrent,
they've got to show
us that they have it,
like North Korea's done.
There are all kinds of
steps, and one weapon
isn't good enough.
I mean, I wrote an
op ed with Jim Walsh
that this whole break out
time thing is too short.
You know, the calculations,
because it assumes one weapon.
So I have an op ed in
Reuters about this.
So there are all
kinds of arguments.
I mean, you could argue forever.
I mean, I don't
expect people who
are what I would call
hardliners to adjust
agree with me because
I've published an op ed.
But I'm just saying-- it's not
so simple, is what I'm saying.
There are arguments.
You have to decide which
is right, because these
are very complicated issues.
So anyway, we have our
Menendez-Kirk bill,
which is in the Senate.
It seems to be in abeyance
for a couple of months.
There's a grace period.
People are working
hard against it,
so it's a very political
thing in both countries.
I know it.
So I sort of wound together the
discussion of two things, Iran
and the NPT.
So I want to come
back to the NPT,
because I embedded the
Iranian discussion in the NPT
discussion.
Because it came up
naturally, that's why.
But so to come back to
it, the next thing that's
going to happen, and
I'm just quoting here,
Stormy weather predicted for
the NPT review in May at the UN.
So I'm actually
quoting an article
from Daryl Kimball of the
Arms Control Association.
I didn't have time to
make all the points,
but in 2005 we had a
disastrous NPT review.
That was under George Bush,
and the nonaligned countries,
Egypt and Sweden and
Denmark and Ireland
and a whole bunch of
countries were very angry.
Particularly at the United
States and George Bush.
It was a disastrous conference.
2010, Barack Obama had
delivered his speech
that he wanted to
eliminate nuclear weapons.
The United States
was very welcome,
and it was a
productive conference.
And they had 22 interrelated
disarmament steps.
I'm not even going to
try to repeat them.
The two major ones were that
the nuclear weapons countries
should give a timetable
for going to zero.
A timetable.
And the second
thing is that they
should convene a
conference in the Middle
East looking towards a
nuclear-free zone in the Middle
East.
That's very delicate,
because getting Israel
to come, getting Iran and Israel
to the table at the same time
is difficult. The whole thing
is difficult, and not just Iran.
AUDIENCE: But the concept was
originally started by Iran
and, I think Egypt, but Israel
was a party to it at one point,
too.
PROFESSOR: They were?
AUDIENCE: They were interested.
They were considering.
PROFESSOR: In my
personal humble opinion,
Israel's interests
are best served
by a nuclear-free zone
in the Middle East.
If you ask me.
I carry zero weight in
Netanyahu's cabinet.
Believe me.
I probably carry-- no, that's
an exaggeration of my influence.
Zero weight is better
than what I have.
So anyway, I'm not even going
to go through any of those,
but the follow through on these
steps have been disappointing.
They've basically
been nonexistent.
There's been basically no
follow through on the 22 points.
And so that's one of
the reasons everyone
who knows anything about
this is predicting that it's
stormy weather ahead, especially
for the nuclear weapons states.
So you can look forward to
some interesting news in May.
I'm kind of running out of
time, so basically Obama
raised a lot of hopes
with his Prague speech
in 2009 talking
about the possibility
of a nuclear-free world.
Of course, he hedged right away,
it won't be reached quickly.
And the US, as long
as the weapons exist,
we're going to have
our little toys, too.
But anyway, it was still the
most forthright statement
since 1945.
I mean, so it was a
breath of fresh air.
And he won the
Nobel Peace Prize.
Probably prematurely,
but who am I to quibble?
So there are many arguments
against nuclear weapons
abolition.
I'm just going to pick one.
Because it eliminates
deterrence, and to me
that's the biggest
argument against it.
And it cannot be achieved.
That's a different kind of
argument, but in my opinion
that's even stronger.
I wouldn't say cannot, but
my personal statement is
it's unlikely.
But that doesn't mean
it's not desirable.
And that doesn't mean that
academics, in particular,
shouldn't talk about it.
That's one of the things
that I have in mind,
and we should have a
long-range view, academics.
That's one of our luxuries.
We can try to look ahead.
And so there are
really two questions.
One, is it desirable in view
of all of the difficulties
with it conceptually?
And then, is it achievable
if it is desirable?
You should only ask
the second question
if the answer to the first
is yes, it's desirable.
And I can't go through
all the arguments,
but deterrence is a very
interesting question.
I think I'm going to convene
a little working group on it.
I've been thinking about it
a lot for the last few years,
and I'm ready to do some more
serious research in this arena.
But the point is that
it's never worked
in the sense of coercing
others to do what you want,
which is the way it's often
used in US diplomatic circles.
I don't know about Russia, but
it's certainly used in the US.
And another problem
with it, as we
heard about India
and Pakistan, is it
enables brinkmanship,
low-level brinkmanship.
In other words it
introduces instabilities,
is what I'm saying.
Deterrence isn't what
it's cracked out to be,
because by having
the weapons, you also
introduce instabilities
in the system,
especially if you have
aggressive basing mechanisms.
This is very important.
And Pakistan certainly
is an example of that.
They have deterred India, but
with a very aggressive basing
mode and threatening verbally.
So, yes, they've deterred,
but is it stable?
How will it last?
They have delegated
command and control
of these local tactical
weapons to field commanders.
Suppose you get a
rogue field commander
who wants to create mischief.
Like you had somebody from
Pakistan goes to Mumbai,
and shoots everyone in
the hotel and so forth.
Or when they entered the
Indian parliament a few years
before that.
So these are actions which don't
introduce love or stability
between countries.
Putting it mildly.
And of course, deterrence
requires rationality,
which is in short supply.
My view.
Accidental use, which
we've talked about.
And of course, it won't
work against terrorists.
They want-- a real terrorist
who's a suicide bombardier
wants death and destruction.
So, boy, that's a bad mixture.
And I think one of the points
that people should not forget
is deterrence requires a
small number of weapons.
AUDIENCE: How many is small?
PROFESSOR: Well, I would
say a hundred is overkill.
So it's less than a
hundred in my view.
I've been giving a number,
and I'll keep giving it.
I have zero weight in
Washington or Moscow,
but that's what I think.
So should we try to
abolish nuclear weapons?
Really is it a good idea?
And so the answer is,
there's no risk-free world.
What you have to
do, when you look
at the arguments
against abolition,
and I've done my best to
look at what I consider
the serious ones,
papers typically
criticize going to zero
because it's risky.
But the question
is what they never
do is talk about
the relative risks.
In other words,
minimizing risks.
How do you minimize the risk?
You're never going
to eliminate risks.
It's impossible.
So the right question is
not to eliminate risks,
you have to ask
the right question.
Every scientist knows that.
The right question here
is minimization of risk.
That's the right question.
How do you minimize risk?
Do you stay on
the present course
or do you try to do
something more creative?
And this is one of
the creative things.
And so the other thing is
that abolition in by itself
is an important goal.
And if we want the
NPT to be healthy,
we better be serious about it.
And those are the fireworks
that I'm talking about.
And the nuclear weapons
states had better
take this into account.
If you want to look
long-range, how patient
are the NPT states going to be?
It's very important.
So, yeah, Obama
has a mixed record.
He's inspired great hopes.
He's done the new START Treaty.
He's improved nuclear security.
He tried to engage
Russia for of the steps.
Actually, that's a dated slide.
Those efforts and now dead.
The Russians effectively
said no, by the way.
So this is bigger than Obama.
You know, Putin can veto
negotiations easily,
as you know.
The nuclear posture review.
In my view, this
is very important.
This is our deployment strategy
was only slightly modified
from earlier years.
We still have too many
warnings on hair trigger alert.
With respect to
North Korea, he talks
about strategic patience,
which is head in the sand,
as far as I'm concerned.
I'm very critical of the North
Korean lack of engagement.
There I'm very
critical of Obama.
AUDIENCE: They're asking
us right now, aren't they?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
They're asking again,
and we're ignoring them.
And I think it's dumb.
And the last thing, again, this
has a lot to do with Congress,
is they're modernizing
nuclear weapons.
Which, again, in
the NPT review is
going to come up for tremendous
criticism, and it should.
And in this day and age
of budgetary restraints,
it should be criticized.
And in terms of
strategic stability,
it should be criticized.
So there are two buzz words.
One is "modernization," and
the other is "maintenance."
So if you have
nuclear weapons, you
have to maintain that
they're usable and safe--
that's maintenance--
without testing.
That's important.
And the other is to
modernize the weapons,
make them more
accurate, and so forth.
And that really
should not be done.
And the two get fused
together, and it's very hard
to tell the detail because
it's all classified.
It's the typical trick
of large bureaucracies.
So anyway, I find some
reason for optimism.
The CTBO, I want
to talk about that,
and I just want to
say a few words.
That is the-- what is it?
The-- I forgot
what it stands for.
It's the worldwide
monitoring system for tests.
It's basically an
international thing.
It's technically fabulous.
I mean, I am really impressed.
They have seismic detectors.
They look for
radioactivity in the air.
And they look for--
there's one more thing.
I'm sorry, I'm blanking.
But anyway, they detected a half
kiloton blast in North Korea.
An unannounced half kiloton
three stations triangulated.
They can tell it
from earthquakes
and conventional explosions.
What happens, just
briefly, is it's the rise
time in the seismic signal.
See, from a chemical-type
explosion, it's slower.
And the instruments have
a fast enough response
time so you could see
the initial overpressure.
It's quite wonderful.
And in several, I think
two out of the three
of the North Korean
tests, all unannounced,
they detected
radioactivity in the air.
I think one of
the xenon isotopes
from the explosion,
which is long-lived.
And so finally, and
I outlined this,
public opinion does count.
So that's one of the things
I take some comfort from.
There are many arms
control organizations.
I'm on the board of the
Council for a Liveable World.
The Arms Control Association
is a wonderful organization
in terms of giving
out information.
And their journal
is quite excellent.
And Peace Action
is a grassroots.
It's all to the good.
I think I've given the answers.
Is the present situation stable?
And my answer is with luck.
And I gave my answer about
abolition of nuclear weapons.
So anyway, there's plenty to
do, and why don't I just stop.
You can look at it.
I'm sure this is only a partial
list of all that can be done.
Some of it can't be done
without Russia, but some can.
For example, we could
reduce, more rapidly,
to the level that Russia has
of launchers and the new START
Treaty.
Russia, for example,
just as an example,
Russia is below the limits
imposed by the START Treaty.
Those limits go
into effect when?
In something like six or
eight years or something?
I forget.
Do you remember?
When they go into effect?
But we could accelerate
those numbers.
You know, like typical
arms control treaties
they go into effect almost
the day they expire.
So it's always too slow
for arms control people.
You know, it's always
welcome, but always too slow.
But you take what you can get.
But again, I want to
just repeat one thing.
The new START Treaty, the
big success of the new START
Treaty, in my
view, which was not
stressed by the newspapers
or the commentators,
is the fact that the
inspections are going on.
And the inspections, in my
view, are much more critical
than the numbers.
There's such overkill whether
it's 1,000 or 1,500 weapons.
I mean, again, this
100 number is overkill.
So to me, it's almost
irrelevant except symbolically
whether you have a
thousand or 1,500.
Below a thousand,
you get into issues
with how many does China
have, and so forth.
I showed you.
So a thousand is roughly
the critical point
in which all the
nuclear weapons states
have to negotiate
with each other,
not just the US and Russia.
Of course, Russia's
critical there.
OK, I'm going to stop.
And of course, there's
been a lot of questions,
but I'm happy for more
discussion or whatever.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You argued that
it's typical to abolish
all the nuclear weapons because
it is used as deterrence.
If it's true, isn't
there another way
of deterrence that would
replace the nuclear weapons?
What is your opinion?
PROFESSOR: Well, first of
all, we already have it,
and it's conventional
smart warfare.
I haven't talked about it.
The United States
calls it Global Strike,
which we're developing.
And that's a whole
other dimension.
It's not the nuclear arms
race, but it was too much
for me to get into that.
But, yes, you're asking
a very good question.
And our conventional military
powers are incredible.
And we can do now,
in many respects,
with conventional
weapons what we
could have done only with
nuclear weapons 20 years ago.
Or even 10 years ago.
And this Global
Strike, which is a way
to strike across the
world with precision,
with conventional weapons, with
missiles, with cruise missiles,
and so forth, is incredible.
And it's all sophisticated
command and control
stuff plus guidance.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So in your
opinion that could
replace the nuclear
[INAUDIBLE] in the future?
PROFESSOR: Well,
replace it in the sense
that you don't have
nuclear weapons.
But then other people are
just as scared as before.
So it's also an aggressive
military posture.
And maybe, in the day
and age when we're really
trying to replace that,
then we can no longer
distinguish between conventional
arms control and nuclear arms
control.
They will become
merged, I think,
as an intellectual subject as
well as a practical matter.
But I'm looking ahead
probably at least 10 years.
But in my view,
that day will come.
So you're really asking
a great question.
AUDIENCE: Disturbing.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Disturbing.
The peace action will
have plenty of work
to do for plenty of time.
I'm afraid.
What can I say?
I'm not happy about
that, but it's a fact.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious
about one thing.
Do you know who in
India or Pakistan
presses that actual button?
PROFESSOR: No, I do not.
AUDIENCE: The reason I'm asking
is is it delegated to some
[? war-grade ?] people or some--
PROFESSOR: OK.
In India-- look,
here's what I know.
I don't know more
than I do know.
What I think is true in India
is that the armed forces
are under civilian control.
But in Pakistan,
that is not true.
So Pakistan is not what you
would call a unitary state.
OK There is no single
command authority.
I mean, there is
officially, but de facto
we know that the Pakistani
military is at least
equal to the civilian branch.
But this ISI, whatever it
is, the security thing,
it seems to be
quasi-independent.
I'm not sure.
So you can see.
But what I'm afraid of
is with this aggressive--
I said it before,
but I'll just repeat
it-- is this aggressive
first strike military nucleus
posture of Pakistan is leading
to delegation of authority
to low-levels where
there's a great danger
of a rogue commander.
So I see Pakistan as
the place with the most
danger of a rogue commander.
And I think I'm not the only
one who thinks this, by the way.
AUDIENCE: Again,
how many weapons
do we think that Pakistan has?
PROFESSOR: Roughly
between 100 and 200.
It's more than 100 now.
AUDIENCE: And they're
making more all the time.
PROFESSOR: They're
They're making them
as fast as they can,
as far as we can tell.
AUDIENCE: The same
in India, also?
PROFESSOR: No.
India seems to be
more relaxed about it.
Both in terms of their
aggressive policy--
they say they won't fire first.
India has a much more
reasonable stated policy of use.
They're much more laid back.
They say they won't
use them first.
They say the Pakistanis are
just going much, much too far.
But on the Indian side,
the problem that I see
is they're not trying for
the political solution.
In other words, their deployment
posture is more sensible,
but they're focused on China.
But they are not-- India--
my big criticism of India
is they are not
solving the problem.
I'm going to come back to that.
AUDIENCE: They're not
initiating any kind of--
PROFESSOR: Right.
They're being much
too slow in trying
to heal problems like
Kashmir and other irritant
points in the relationship.
I mean, they're not going
to disappear overnight,
but they could do things.
And I can point to
some literature,
but I'm not a real
expert, by the way.
The United States is
not being evenhanded,
and that's a mistake.
That's a basic American mistake.
So, you know, I've been
critical since the beginning.
I'm not the only
one on this basis.
I think the predictable
is happening.
They're just spurring Pakistan
into a more frenzied state
of nuclear weapons development.
It's unfortunate.
But we're doing something
we don't want to see happen.
We deplore it on one hand,
and then we encourage it
indirectly on the other.
So it's a contradictory policy.
It's unfortunate.
They should know better,
but there they're
letting commercial
interests override this.
This is a tug of war.
The United States
says many interests.
AUDIENCE: Are you saying
the commercial interest
with respect to
power plant sales?
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: It's sort of
interesting in that this
got started what?
In 2005 or 06?
PROFESSOR: Under Bush somehow.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: And in the
meantime, of course,
all the American
companies are now
owned by Japanese
or French companies.
So what we're doing--
PROFESSOR: Well, we also
make military hardware sales
to India, which is increasing.
That was-- oh, that was one of
the other things from the Obama
visit, the sale of conventional
military equipment to India
is going up for the first
time in a long time.
So that was a big
success, I guess.
AUDIENCE: So that was a
part of the recent trip?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Yes.
I forgot to mention that.
You reminded me.
Thank you.
Thank you for coming.